♪
>> SO I JUST HEARD THAT THEY
BROKE INTO THE OFFICE OF ONE
OF MY PERSONAL ATTORNEYS.
>> YESTERDAY WE HAD THE FBI
RAID THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEY'S RESIDENCE AND HIS
BUSINESS AND GOT INFORMATION
THAT HAS -- THAT IS
PRIVILEGED INFORMATION.
WHAT A DOUBLE STANDARD WE
SEE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT,
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE IS
ALIVE AND WELL.
BUT THERE IS AN EXCEPTION
WHEN THE ATTORNEY MIGHT BE
INVOLVED IN A CRIME OR
FRAUD.
>> IT'S PART OF A JUDICIAL
PROCESS.
HE SHOULD LET IT WORK ITS
WAY THROUGH.
>> Bret: DESPITE A LOT OF
THE DAY BEING TAKEN UP BY
THE CEO OF FACEBOOK
TESTIFYING ON CAPITOL HILL,
THIS IS STILL A BIG STORY
HERE IN THIS TOWN.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS
WEIGHING IN ON HIS PERSONAL
ATTORNEY AND THE RAID ON HIS
OFFICE AND APARTMENT OR
HOTEL ROOM.
TWEETING:  ATTORNEY/CLIENT
PRIVILEGE IS DEAD AND A
TOTAL WITCH-HUNT.
JUST A SHORT TIME AGO,
MICHAEL COHEN, THAT
ATTORNEY, HAD A QUOTE TO
CNN, QUOTE:  I AM UNHAPPY TO
HAVE MY PERSONAL RESIDENCE
AND OFFICE RAIDED BUT I WILL
TELL THAT YOU MEMBERS OF THE
FBI THAT CONDUCTED THE
SEARCH AND SEIZURE WERE ALL
EXTREMELY PROFESSIONAL
COURTEOUS AND RESPECTFUL.
I THANKED THEM AT THE
CONCLUSION.
YOU HEARD SOME OF THE PUSH
BACK OF THIS ACTION.
HERE IS ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
>> THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS
DAY TODAY FOR LAWYER-CLIENT
RELATIONS.
I DEAL WITH CLIENTS ALL THE
TIME.
I TELL THEM ON MY WORD OF
HONOR THAT WHAT YOU TELL ME
IS SACCO
IS SACKO
IS SACK SACCO
IS SACK SACKO
IS SACK SACK SACROSANCT.
GIVE IT TO ANOTHER FBI AGENT
AND SAY YOU ARE THE FIRE
WALL.
>> Bret: DERSHOWITZ IS AT
THE WHITE HOUSE RIGHT NOW.
HAD A MEETING WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND IS APPARENTLY
HAVING DINNER WITH HIM.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL
JONAH GOLDBERG, SENIOR
EDITOR AT NATIONAL REVIEW.
MARA LIASSON NATIONAL
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT OF
RADIO AND MATTHEW WASHINGTON
FREE BEDONE.
OKAY, MARA.
>> THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION
THAT'S GETTING AWFULLY CLOSE
TO THE PRESIDENT.
I THOUGHT WHAT WAS REALLY
INTERESTING YESTERDAY IS YOU
HAD TOM POLITE PUSH BACK
FROM REPUBLICANS.
HAD YOU MITCH MCCONNELL
SAYING THE INVESTIGATION
SHOULD GO FORWARD.
JOHN CORNYN SAYING THAT
MUELLER'S REPORT SHOULD
DEFINITELY BE GIVEN TO
CONGRESS, WHICH IS NOT
REQUIRED.
YOU ALSO HAD CHUCK GRASSLEY
SAYING IT WOULD BE SUICIDE
TO TALK ABOUT FIRING MUELLER
AND THIS COMES AFTER PEOPLE
WHO ARE TALKING TO THE
PRESIDENT OUTSIDE ADVISORS
ARE SAYING THAT HE IS AS MAD
AS HE HAS EVER WITHIN
AS HE HAS EVER BITHIN
AS HE HAS EVER BEEHIN
AS HE HAS EVER BEENIN
AS HE HAS EVER BEEN AND THE
IDEA OF FIRING JEFF SESSIONS
IS VERY, VERY LIVE.
>> Bret: SESSIONS,
ROSENSTEIN.
>> THAT'S THE WAY YOU GET
RID OF MULLER.
>> Bret: ROSENSTEIN REALLY.
>> REPLACE WITH SOMEONE NOT
RECUSED AND FIRE ROSENSTEIN.
THAT'S HOW HE GET RID OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> Bret: YOU HEARD PUNDITRY.
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION
DESIGNED TO HAVE THE
PRESIDENT DO WHAT HE IS
CONTEMPLATING DOING FIRE
MUELLER AND THEREBY MAKE THE
CASE FOR OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE PRETTY CLEAR.
>> WEIRD THING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT FORGET WHETHER IT'S
POLITICAL SUICIDE OR ALL
THOSE THINGS, IT WOULD BE
POINTLESS TO FIRE MUELLER
BECAUSE MUELLER IS NOT DOING
THE MICHAEL COHEN
INVESTIGATION.
HE HANDED IT OFF TO THE U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK WHO IS
NOT WORKING FOR MULLEN.
IF YOU FIRED MUELLER, THAT
THING CONTINUES TO GO.
ONLY WAY TO GET RID OF THAT
INVESTIGATION IS TO FIRE THE
TRUMP APPOINTED INTERIM
DIRECTOR OF THE U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
YOU HAVE GOT TO PUT SOMEBODY
IN THERE WHO WILL THEN KILL
THIS INVESTIGATION.
POLITICALLY, THAT IS JUST --
THE OPTICS OF TRYING TO MAKE
IT ALL GO AWAY NOW, I JUST
THINK ARE ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE.
BUT MAYBE I'M WRONG.
>> Bret: MATTHEW?
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO ASK HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOUND
HIMSELF IN THIS SITUATION TO
BEGIN WITH AND THAT WAS BY
FIRING JAMES COMEY.
AND AFTER COMEY'S FIRING,
COMEY LEAKED THE MEMOS WHICH
THEN LED TO THE APPOINTMENT
OF THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
SO NOW IF PRESIDENT TRUMP
THINKS CAN HE FIX THIS
SITUATION BY FIRING THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
THE FIRST FIRING LED TO MORE
PROBLEMS FOR HIM.
>> Bret: GO AHEAD.
>> THERE IS ONE SITUATION
WHERE MAYBE HE COULD DO THIS
IF THE REPUBLICANS HOLD ONTO
THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
THEN, MAYBE HE COULD FIRE
HIM.
BECAUSE IF HE FIRED HIM NOW,
IT WOULD HELP DEMOCRATS, I
THINK, IN THE ELECTION.
AND, IF DEMOCRATS TOOK OVER,
THEY WOULD -- EVEN IF
MUELLER WAS FIRED, THEY
WOULD PROBABLY HAVE HIM UP
TESTIFYING SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN A
DISRUPTER TO WASHINGTON.
HE HAS EVERYBODY REACTING TO
HIS ACTIONS WITH ONE
EXCEPTION.
ROBERT MUELLER.
HE'S THE OTHER DISRUPTER.
THE TWO OF THEM NOW IN
COMBAT COULD LEAD TO A VERY
COMBUSTIBLE SITUATION.
>> Bret: IT'S DEFINITELY
COMBUSTIBLE.
SPEAKING OF COMBUSTIBLE ON
SYRIA IS IMMINENT.
SOME ACTION MAY BE IMMINENT.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT TODAY.
>> WE ARE MAKING A DECISION
AS TO WHAT WE DO WITH
RESPECT TO THE HORRIBLE
ATTACK THAT WAS MADE NEAR
DAMASCUS.
AND IT WILL BE MET
FORCEFULLY.
>> WE SPEAK TODAY AND WE SEE
THE SUFFERING OF ASYRIAN
PEOPLE.
AND ME AND THE PRESIDENT WE
SEE EYE TO EYE THAT THIS
MATTER HAS TO STOP
IMMEDIATELY.
WE CAN'T TOLERATE WITH A WAR
CRIMINAL.
WE CAN'T TOLERATE WITH
SOMEONE WHO KILL HALF A
MILLION OF HIS OWN PEOPLE.
THIS MATTER SHOULD END
IMMEDIATELY.
>> Bret: THEIR MEETING WITH
THE OVAL OFFICE COUNTY QATAR
EMERE.
PRESIDENT WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR SUPPORTING TERRORISM.
QUITE A TOURNAMENT ABOUT
HERE.
>> HOW FAST THINGS CHANGE IN
TRUMP WORLD WHETHER IT'S IN
FOREIGN POLICY OR
EXADVISORS.
EVERYTHING IS PRETTY FLUID
AND FLEXIBLE AS HE LIKES TO
SAY.
>> Bret: WE DO THINK THAT
THERE IS LIKELY SOME
IMMINENT ACTION?
>> I THINK THERE IS.
TO ME THE QUESTION IS IT
GOING TO BE LIKE WHAT HE DID
ALMOST EXACTLY A YEAR AGO
WHERE HE HIT AN AIRFIELD.
DIDN'T DETER THEM FROM USING
CHEMICAL WEAPONS AGAIN.
SOMETHING MORE.
TAKE OUT SYRIAN AIR FORCE
RISK CONFRONTATION WITH
RUSSIA.
WHAT'S HE GOING TO DO THAT
WILL ACTUALLY HAVE DETERRENT
EFFECT?
LAST THING HE DID DIDN'T
WORK.
>> Bret: JONAH.
>> I THINK DONALD TRUMP
NEEDS TO DO SOMETHING.
HE DIDN'T CALL IT A RED
LINE, BUT BY DOING IT THE
FIRST TIME HE BASICALLY SET
A PRECEDENT THAT SAYS, YOU
KNOW.
>> HE DID ACTUALLY CALL IT A
RED LINE THE FIRST TIME.
HE SAID THERE WERE A LOT OF
RED LINES.
>> MY POINT IS THAT IT WOULD
BE A LOSS OF CREDIBILITY FOR
DONALD TRUMP AND THE UNITED
STATES IF HE DIDN'T DO IT
NOW.
I THINK HE WILL DO IT NOW.
HE SHOULD DO IT NOW.
WHAT HE DOES, I'M NOT SURE.
THE REAL PROBLEM FOR ME IS
SYRIA IS JUST LOOKING TO BE
BASICALLY THE BALKANS OF THE
21st CENTURY WITH SO
MANY -- I MEAN, IT'S NOT
EVEN THE SPANISH CIVIL WAR
ANYMORE WHICH AT LEAST HAD
TWO SIDES TO IT THE PLACE IS
JUST A HOT MESS AND HOW WE
FIGURE OUT A STRATEGY ABOUT
HOW TO FIX THE PLACE OR DO
ANYTHING OR WHETHER WE
SHOULD EVEN TRY OR AT LEAST